you gain status by giving more to the
group than you get it's how it works the
people who take from the group and only
want to get status they only going to
get status from the group end up getting
banished by the group and batted down
because everyone wants to keep that
person down because they don't serve
anyone else and so it was only by
realizing that I had to give my life in
order to get it I had to serve because
when you serve someone you're giving
them status you're increasing your
regard for others all of these things
started compounding when I realized that
truth that humility is not thinking less
of yourself it's thinking more about
other people and increasing your regard
for their needs and if you do that I
promise you you will have all the status
you want